I'm Emily Ratajkowski I'm Erin Paul and
we are doing a wired auto-complete
interview very excited
[Music]
is Aaron Paul in the movie chips I don't
I don't think so what is what's that all
right um no I I am NOT in the movie
chips is Aaron Paul related to Milly
Bobby Brown yes yes wait are you yeah
you didn't know that that's insane
yeah yeah she's my daughter my adopted
daughter oh you can ask her okay
is Aaron Paul's voice in black mirror uh
yes i and one of the episodes in black
beard you do have a very distinctive
voice is Aaron Paul vegan yes
No I know the answer to this yeah no no
nothing against vegans but I'm not one
hi watched me I'm just eat bacon yeah I
watch you eat bacon yeah I love bacon
Emily erotic house key what is Emily
erotic house keys workouts actually no I
know what you're know but recently I
started going did she is I've recently
started going to the gym I do stuff like
ankle weights and like bands like you
know little weights yeah you like put
ankle weights on your and used to walk
around and then you like put your leg up
like okay multiple time like this okay
yeah oh yeah that's that's right how is
that working out for you good I haven't
been in three weeks um what is my
Roddick housekeys diet Aaron why don't
you um pasta wine a little a little
portion of salad but mainly sauce and no
no key when I eat that and I do this
little muffin Tom is growing so sweet
though yeah but I but I have a baby so
I'm throwing my dad bought I'm proud of
it what is in erotic house keys hair
color I did brown I've actually never
colored my hair so this is it
it's brown also why why we're people ask
that like can't you just like Google
image that's me
what is erotic housekeys face shape
alright what is your fascia what do you
think like what would you say that is
like a egg shape that's weird
no so yeah it's like egg shaped what
would it's a nice egg shape what awards
has Aaron Paul won yeah I've won some
awards yeah yeah don't worry about it
yeah I want something how tall is Aaron
Paul uh you know I'm holding on to I'm
five eight and a half sometimes you know
I like to say five nine but half all
right how did Aaron Paul meet Lauren
person there you go those are partying
or seek Ian Percy Kendra um médico
chillin
actually can I just say that her phone
number still saved in your phone is born
in Coachella which is really cute I
didn't know her last name
um what cars Aaron Paul driving in Need
for Speed okay uh I drew up a lot of
cars in Need for Speed but my
character's car need for speed which is
now my car it's a 69 Torino how oh it
starts up how how is Emily my Kowski
name pounds well you actually did it
right Radek a schematic ascii the jason
it's easy once you know what once you
know but if you're you know if you're
saying it in polish it's a rat the
Gulf's key it's such a good strong name
Thanks yep if this want me to change
that name didn't I'm glad you didn't
alright uh how is an excuse husband um
he's good alright thanks for asking yeah
thanks okay
how does Emily run a cascade to her hair
um wash it uh-huh blow-dry it sometimes
I don't blow dry it how often do you
wash it every day uh every other day
didn't wash it this morning but it seems
to be okay right
I really had much options with my looks
good
Erin oh just a straight up Erin Potter
and Paul
can Aaron Paul sing absolutely not sadly
no but there is a singer by the name of
Aaron Paul I think that's where the
confusion oh we got hilarious people
think you're like putting on music
yeah it's I think it's on one of my
credits on IMDB change that Ken Aaron
Paul dry no no yes very good right yeah
I I love to drive love traffic love it
who's Aaron Paul's brother uh well my
brother is Steven without Steve and
we're on a cow ski what is Emily Monica
house keys Instagram and radda radda I
think people know that maybe more than
they know my heart I don't know what car
does Emily Ratajkowski drive mm-hmm well
I Drive a Prius now but I used to drive
a really shitty Nissan Versa that I got
when I was 18 do you ever drive that
Prius oh you're never here
yeah I know I Drive it when I marry is
I'm Loretta Kowski Irish
fun fact yes my middle name is O'Hara oh
oh yeah I love Ireland and I've been
going every year in my life that's your
favorite beer um I likes mythix okay
where did my rata Kowski nice da
Mustangs ah must Angeles California
public high school my dad was the art
teacher okay
where did Aaron Paul get married uh we
got married in Malibu um where did Aaron
Paul go to college fun fact I didn't
look where um where was Aaron Paul born
I was born on my bathroom floor and a
little does that read yeah my mom
delivered me herself before the
ambulance could get there
so she just my dad happened to be out of
town and she had three little babies and
then I was her fourth where is Aaron
Paul right now what feel to uh you know
just uh hanging out with you I'm gonna
start doing this I'm just gonna go go
where there
where is our employer is he I'm gonna
Google that too who are Emily erotic
cows Keys parents uh John radical scheme
Oh Kathleen bow clean I love your
relationship with that Thanks only child
that's so sweet um okay who are Emily
Ratajkowski siblings funny you should
mention it I don't have any
where does Emily Ratajkowski
come from well you ready um I was born
in London but I'm from Encinitas
California San Diego where did Emily
Ratajkowski
get married courthouse New York City Bay
Bay god I love a good good courthouse
water yeah it was good it was fun my
personal favorite from that collection
was where's Erin Paul right now because
I love the idea that people around the
world are just wondering like what what
are you up to you know like I like that
as well yeah this was fun dream come
true a dream car